Rob's World
Hey everyone, and welcome
back I hope you all had a great holiday
season and you're enjoying the new year
in 2019.
The comments on the last video
The Origami Mini Boomerang were great
and thank you guys so much for the
support over all these years.
I've been on YouTube now for over 10 years and it
really means a lot to me. Today I'd like
to show you my own version of the
Origami Mini Fireworks which is based
off the Infinity Kaleidoscope tutorial
that I did, except it's made from one
piece of paper so it's a lot better than
making all those modules and putting
them together. Once you have a paper
you're ready to go and if you do enjoy
the video at the end don't forget to
like it down below and also comment and
subscribe to shows some support!
The size of the mini infinity firework depends on the paper you use. If you want a larger
one you can use 11 by 17 inch paper or
you can also use eight-and-a-half by 14
legal sized
to get a mid sized one however if you
want a cool mini hand size one you can
use eight-and-a-half by 11 letter sized
paper like this one.  I prefer to use the
color paper because it's slightly
sturdier than white and I find it works
better so that's what I'm going to use
We're going to first turn the
8.5" by 11" into a 1-to-4
proportion paper, make all the pre
creases and finally once we get this
accordion thing, we can then take the two
ends and we can join them together just
like this in order to get the mini
infinity firework.
To get a 1:4 proportion paper like this we need to
first divide the paper into four
sections. Now, I've already pre-creased
this one but to do it we first fold the
paper in half by taking the left side
and folding it to the right side and
then rotate it so the open edges are on
top. Take the top edge fold it down and
then flip it over and do the same. Crease
it sharply and when you open it'll look
like an M from the side. Airplane fold
both corners in just like this and at
this point if you want to take a ruler
and draw a line at the base of the
corner triangles and cut it you can but
I prefer to flip it over like this fold
the top edge down until the edge is in
line with the triangles, and then make a
nice sharp crease on the top there and
then you could tear it
Now you have a 1 to 4 proportion
paper. The next step is going to be to
split it into 8 sections just like this
I'm going to draw on the center just so
you could see it a little bit easier
because it does become important.
To split it into 8 sections we're going to
take this line here in between these two
right boxes and we're going to just
pinch it like this
and we're going to bring it directly
into the middle line just like that and
what that does is it splits this box in
half so let's go ahead and do that.
Just pinch it bring it into the middle right
on top of that line I drew and then
you're going to press in the middle of
this right box here. So just press right
down here.  Then we can take the outside
edge and also fold it directly into the
middle. Once it's there then once again
make a crease do the same with the left side
So just pinch the left side
bring it into the center also and then
crease it on the left box and then fold
the left edge into the center and crease
both sides sharply. When you open it
you'll see we've now split the paper
into eight sections and I'm just going
to draw on them so you can see them a
little easier because they become
important when we make the diagonal folds
Now that we split the paper into
eight sections it's important that I
emphasize that all of the vertical folds
must be Mountain folds meaning we're
going to fold downwards on each of these
folds so let's go ahead and do that now
So let's just fold downwards on all of
them and crease across. I've also marked
the center line as darker so that it's
easier to distinguish and what we're
going to do is to turn this into
something that looks like this. It has
eight sections and each section has two
X's on top of each other. To do that
we're going to start with the diagonal
folds going this direction and then
we're going to go in this direction. We're going to first take the corner
here and we're going to take this top
edge and fold the corner into this first
line just like this. Once it's lined up
then you can make a crease on the
outside, then we're going to go to the
second line in so this one has already
been made so all you need to do is to
fold it down and just reinforce it by
sharpening it then we're going to go to
the third one just go right there line
and make sure that this line on the
bottom also corresponds with the bottom
as well so that everything is lined up.
Make a nice sharp crease and then
finally go in directly to the center
line here. Once it's lined up again make
a crease. Now we could flip it over just
like this and we're going to do the same
with the upper right so just like before
go to the first line the second line the
third line and then finally the center. When you open it up you'll see that
we did all of them except one from here
to here. What you do is you just take
it fold it down to the center and then
just shift this edge over to the next
line to the left of the center.  So just
shift it over and crease like before.
Now we finished all of the diagonal
lines going this way and I'm just going
to draw on them so you could see it a
little bit easier.  Now we're going to do
the same going the other way so we're
going to take the upper left corner and
fold it in to the first line also just
like this make a nice sharp crease and
it's basically the same thing. We're
going to fold it all the way to the
middle just like before so just like
before just go to the second, one the
third one, and then the middle. You
flip it over do the same thing bring the
upper left down to each line and then
finally when you get to the middle just
open one up and then shift it over give
it a nice crease and now we finished all
of the diagonal creases and I'm just
going to draw on the remaining ones
again so you could see them easier. So
you should have a paper that looks just
like this. Alright guys so we're almost
done we just need to divide the eight
sections into 16 sections vertically and
then we can create something like this
and join it together. You already know
what to do you just basically bring
these edges into the center until we
have split everything into 16 sections
so let's go ahead and do that just pinch
it here and bring it into the center and
then make a crease right along here and
just keep on bringing the edges into the
center just like that so just keep
bringing those Mountain folds into the
center until you have split everything
into 16 sections and each of those X's
has a vertical line through it and then
we can reinforce the creases by just
going over the outside and do the same
with
other side. Now we can open it and you'll
see we've divided everything into 16
sections. Now this is very important--We
need to make sure that all of these
vertical folds are Mountain folds so I'm
going to hold it like this and I'm just
going to fold downwards or backwards
like this so that all of the folds are
folded downwards so just like before
we're going to crease downwards on all
of those vertical lines and making sure
that they're all nice sharp mountain
folds just continue throughout the rest
of the paper now that we've done that
I'm just going to reinforce that all of
the diagonal folds are valley folds so
just take it and then just push it and
then go through all of the folds this is
very important it makes it 10 times
easier trust me so I'm just taking the
paper and just going back over those X
folds or diagonal Valley folds we made.
Now that we finished all the pre creases
we can make it into this and then finish
up by joining the ends. Alright,
everyone once you've reinforced all of
these vertical fold mountain creases so
they're folded downwards sharply so that
they look like an upside-down V and
you've gone through that throughout the
whole paper and you've also done all of
these diagonal fold Valley creases so
that they look like a V then you should
notice that the paper sort of takes
shape you'll notice that there is a
center row of diamonds and each of the
diamonds should have a mountain fold in
it now if any part of the paper is
protruding or sticking up like this at
the mountain fold you're gonna push
inwards on it so just push on either
side of these diamonds throughout the
whole paper and that will pop anything
that's sticking up down so that each of
these little diamonds in the center row
has a mountain fold you'll also notice
that there are two outer rows of
diamonds around the center row and on
top you should notice that we have these
upside-down triangles and they're all
inside reverse fold it so that it looks
like a zigzag all the way across the
paper on both ends now if you turn it
upside down remember this is going to be
the inside the side that we drew on if
you turn it upside down you can more
easily see that
there is a center row here and on either
side there are those two diamond rows
what we're going to do is we're just
going to take the two diamonds that are
on top and touching each other we're
just going to bring them and pinch them
together like this so just go through
the paper and just take the tips and
just pinch them together like that and
you'll notice it'll kind of collapse
things in the middle as well the center
diamond so just pinch it all the way
throughout the paper so your paper
should look a little bit more like this
now when you flip it back to the inside
you should have all Mountain folds on
these Center diamonds and you could see
that really easy if you hold it like
this you could see all these little
Mountain folds that are sticking up here
what we're going to do is we're going to
start with the end here and I'm just
going to grab it and this point on the
end is going to be brought down so
you're gonna basically take this first
diamond and squish it together like this
what you're going to do is take your
pointer fingers and push on top of these
inside reverse folds these upside down
diamonds and you're going to put your
middle finger behind the triangle here
on top and you're going to squish it
down together then you're just going to
move forward this way so you're going to
push on these inside reverse-fold these
upside down triangles and push them
together so just take them push them
together move your middle finger behind
the triangle right here and right here
and then bring it to your thumb so just
squish it then just keep doing that push
these two together and squish it push
and then pull on the back of this
triangle here this inside reverse fold
like this and just keep doing that so
just push and pull push and squish push
and squish and then for the end it's the
same thing you're just gonna push these
two together and you'll see that these
little tips these tips will go together
and these edges will meet and then you
could just flatten everything out just
like that and that's basically how to
collapse it so it should look just like
this once you've finished you'll see on
the bottom you have eight diamonds and
you'll see on top that all of these
inside
verse folds our zigzagged now they
should be tucked in if you have
something like this where it's kind of
tucked out just like that
then all you need to do is to open it
and you just need to tuck it in like
this and then flatten it out and you're
ready to move on once your paper looks
like mine with eight of these triangles
on the top eight on the bottom as well
as the eight diamonds like this we're
going to interlock the two ends by
overlapping these left two triangles
with the right two triangles just to
help you visualize that I've marked the
top of the two triangles on the right
and I've also marked the two triangles
on the left along with the inside here
as you'll notice on the left side of
this diamond I drew an X and all the way
on this point on the end here I've also
drawn a half of an X because these are
the points that are going to be
overlapped to do that I'm going to take
the left side first triangle here on the
top and I'm going to pinch it between my
thumb and pointer I'm going to do the
same with the right side just like this
now I'm going to bring the left side and
the right side together and remember the
left side is going to get tucked in to
the right side okay so what I'm going to
do is to take the right triangle and put
it right behind the left triangle just
like this and as you'll see I also drew
an arrow on the corner because that's
going to be tucked in right there once
you overlap those two triangles then you
could hold it together with your left
pointer and left thumb and we're also
going to take this top triangle here and
tuck it under this one to do that we
need to get this end point on to the
area where the X is so what I do is I
kind of lift it up like this and then I
shift it with my middle finger like that
so make sure that that point is over and
into that X area see as you'll see it
doesn't want to go there so I lift it up
and then I grab the point here and I
shift it until it's underneath this X
okay so you need to work with that it's
gonna be a little bit of a puzzle but
you'll eventually figure it out if you
mark the end triangles like that it
should look just like this once you get
it in once they're tucked in I'm going
to pinch them together like this and
also pinch the top and there you go your
mini infinity firework is completed and
you just need to spin it to do that it's
basically going to take your thumbs and
pull
we're at the same time talking from the
back and pushing upward just like that
thank you so much for watching the video
I hope you liked it and I am looking
forward to and I'm really excited about
making some new stuff this year I'd like
to switch it up and bring some new fresh
content to my channel that's fun
educational entertaining and that you
guys will enjoy there's so many things
that I like crafts cooking chess pool
poker paper juggling puzzles riddles
movies anime just to name a few so if
you have any suggestions please be sure
to let me know down below and be sure to
stick around and hit that notification
bell looking forward to the rest of 2019
and I hope you have a purrfect day